[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories my name is j and I'll be your
host today so without further Ado let's
dive into today's episode and embark on
a great journey together get ready to be
engaged entertained and inspired today's
topic will be about the impact of social
media on my friends and on teenagers in
general well what exactly is social
media may be asking social media can be
summed up as a means of interactions
among people in which they create share
Andor exchange information and ideas in
Virtual communities and networks
originally social media was intended to
Simply Be a method for people to
interact with their friends and family
these days however social media has
developed and expanded to serve a
variety of different purposes examples
of popular social media sites are Tik
Tok Instagram Twitter Snapchat and
Facebook recent studies from January
2023 have shown that nearly 4.8 billion
people around the world actively use
social media with a number only seeming
to grow so it's not a surprise that it
has such an effect on so many people
specifically adult Ence who are growing
through a phase of intense physical and
psychological
development with that being said let's
dive into today's topic let's discuss
the negative and positive effects of
social media on today's
adolescence let's start off with the
negative effects social media has driv
countless of ordinary teenage boys and
girls to attempt to emulate the opulence
for their favorite celebrity double
digit Millionaire on their Instagram
feed it has caused countless teenagers
to load themselves simply because they
aren't capable of keeping up with crazy
standards which are especially
unattainable for someone their age you
may be curious about why these teenagers
try so hard to meet these unrealistic
standards and the answer is simple they
aren't aware of all the hard work that
goes behind creating this image of
perfection we see they compare
themselves to millionaires who have
entire teams which specifically work to
create a false image of flawlessness not
being aware that this absolutely not
what a normal person looks like and when
they see their peers comply with these
crazy standards it only creates this
weird type of chain reaction which only
pressures the ones not complying to do
the same making them think it's normal
this has created a new generation of
teenagers with low self-esteem caused by
the fact that they cannot keep up with
the insane standards they've set upon
themselves a
2017 study based on a survey taken by
almost 6,000 adolescent students show
that there is a very apparent
correlation between low self-esteem
depression symptoms and addiction like
use of social media sites in teenagers
another study also supports this showing
that usage of social media can lead
teenagers to experience lowquality sleep
anxiety and low self-esteem personally
I've seen the effects that social media
has on my friends I've seen how it can
ruin someone's self-esteem and belief in
themselves how it subliminally imposes
doubts into one's mind most people under
the quote unquote spell of social media
don't even realize how abnormal their
thought processes having such negative
thoughts during such a crucial
transitional phase like adolescence is
bound to have negative long-term effects
another negative aspect of social media
is how it makes you feel addicted to it
social media addiction goes hand to hand
with dopamine addiction now if you're
wondering what dopamine is dopamine is
essentially a feel-good chemical linked
to pleasurable activities such as sex
food and social interaction functional
brain Imaging studies show that in
response to a variety of rewarding
social stimuli such as attractive faces
positive emotional expressions and one's
own social status dopaminergic award
pathways are activated social media
sites are specifically designed to cause
your brain to produce dopamine by
exposing you to the aformentioned
rewarding social stimuli making you want
to come back for more that is how social
media gets you hooked social media
addiction also creates several other
problems alongside having a negative
impact on your Mental Health social
media addiction additionally causes
problems when it comes to time
management a lot of people will find it
hard not to procrastinate when you
consider the dopamine aspect of social
media addiction alone but then there's
also the problems that come with having
access to a virtually endless library of
information and entertainment social
media apps literally customize their
fees to be specifically appealing to the
user's taste it's very difficult to not
get sucked in these sites and lose track
of your time not only does this lead to
procrastination when it comes to
schoolwork but the same factors can
affect sleep as well studies suggests
that there is a negative relation
between use of technology and sleep
stating that social media May directly
affect sleep in three different ways it
either replaces sleep due to its time
cons assuming nature it interferes with
sleep through its increased
psychological arousal caused by the
simulating content of the material or
through bright light exposure quality of
sleep is also proven to be connected to
mental health at this point it must have
already become apparent that all
negative aspects of social media
addiction seem to be intertwined with
each other so how do we tackle these
problems headon first off we must start
educating teenagers about the dangers of
social media and how it can affect your
mind if people are aware of the problems
that are caused and why these problems
are caused they are less susceptible to
being harmed by social media and getting
addicted to it we must promote digital
literacy programs in our schools and in
our communities so we can protect people
another thing we must do is get the
parents involved parents must be
monitoring what their children do online
and how much they're active on social
media sit If the parents are well
informed on what their child is doing
and is the one managing how much screen
time their child gets then a lot of
sleep and time managing problems are
easily solved studies show that good
relationship with parents effective
parenting and parental emotional
availability could provide adolescence
with a stable and safe environment for
growth and help prevent them from
developing internet addiction another
crucial step would be promoting offline
interactions encouraging teenagers to
interact with one another in real life
so they understand the importance of
real life connections and now there is
even more happiness and satisfaction
from interacting with real people on a
daily basis rather than wasting your
time on your phone and to introduce my
next talking point we also have to teach
teenagers what the positive aspects of
social media are and how to utilize the
positive aspects to their gain but first
we must Define what the positive aspects
of social media are so what are these
positive aspects in my opinion there are
multiple positive aspects of social
media however there are two main things
I'd like to focus on education/ learning
and online health support first off I'll
start with the importance of Education
in relation to social media as we
mentioned before social media allows
access to a virtually endless library of
information which you have at your
fingertips for free all provided by
credible sources if the user is smart
enough social media can even be utilized
to conduct thought experiments and other
experiments of this sort in fact the
script for this podcast I'm writing
right now would be very difficult to
make without access to social media
social media can also provide teachers
with the means of communication with
their students even outside of school
but it doesn't only stop there social
media allows students to network and
create connections with other people
which become useful in the future we
must teach young people how to properly
utilize social media to put themselves
at an advantage in academics
the second good aspect of social media
is online health support social media
allows access to mental health
communities for those who feel like they
cannot open up about their issues to
their real life friends and family these
online Health communities provide
patients and their families means to
learn about illnesses to seek and offer
social support and to connect with
others suffering from similar illnesses
one in four of people with an illness
have gone online to find other people
who share similar
experiences because they simply can't
find other people like them in real life
without great difficulty teenagers with
various condition such as cancer
diabetes and other rare diseases have
benefited greatly from these networks
emotional and informational support it
is especially crucial that teenagers
have access to this type of support as
they often might feel Outcast due to
whatever illness they may be suffering
from and are in a time in their life
when they need social interaction and
support even more than before
[Music]